pendant ce temps parallèlement son
collègue rené monory invité les
principaux responsables de la politique
de l'économie et des problèmes de
société à venir se pencher sur
précisément l'économie des années 80
cela se passait à l'unesco et ce fut
l'occasion pour les participants
d'aborder tout d'abord le dossier le
plus crucial celui des rapports avec le
tiers-monde
souvenons nous de ces images qui nous
avait bouleversés samedi cet enfant
meurt de faim au cm2 vous a déjà montré
samedi sept scènes insoutenables elle se
passe en ouganda où 140 mille personnes
tentent de survivre de survie dans un
pays ravagé par la sécheresse qui laisse
les greniers vide à quelques heures
d'avion de nos villes et de nos lumières
on meurt de faim symbole d'un monde
déréglé à la recherche d'un nouvel
équilibre économique
on nous propose des régimes
amaigrissants pour perdre des calories
qui manque tant là bas c'est démagogique
sûrement d'opposer la mort d'un enfant a
de la cellulite c'est peut être le seul
moyen de briser le ronronnement des
statistiques puissant millions d'êtres
humains vivre dans un état de pauvreté
absolue cela signifie pas de quoi bien
se nourrir pas de quoi se loger et
encore moins se soigner ou aller à
l'école l'augmentation du prix du
pétrole a frappé de plein fouet les
économies du tiers-monde incapables de
payer leurs énergies
seppi se sont endettés regardez ces deux
chiffres
aujourd'hui la dette du tiers-monde
représente 450 milliards de dollars soit
environ quatre fois le budget d'un pays
comme la france
coïncidence des chiffres c'est
exactement ce que dépense chaque année
les nations du monde pour acheter des
armes
de plus en plus son estime que la paix
mondiale ne sera pas seulement assurée
par les fusils mais aussi par davantage
de justice
le problème du tiers monde et politique
économique et financier pendant les
années 60 nous avons privilégié notre
propre croissance économique
aujourd'hui c'est au moment où le monde
occidental connaît à son tour la crise
qui doit faire un effort pour protéger
sa croissance pour la partager
une croissance qui partout s'est
essoufflé c'est la raison pour laquelle
six français sur dix estiment selon un
sondage de la sofres que la période de
forte croissance ne reviendra plus
jamais mais chose est certaine on ne
peut pas y avoir d'un côté une ville
riche l'occident de l'autre
faubourg pauvre le tiers-monde